[موسيقى]
رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الثاني عشر لتركيا
واكثر الزعماء حكما للبلاد كرئيس للوزراء
ورئيس الجمهوريه خلال عقدين من حكمه نشا
جيل كامل هو الجيل زد او جيل الالفيه الذي
لم يعرف حاكما غير اردوغان اكثر من سته
ملايين شاب سيصوتون للمره الاولى ومجمل
اعداد الجيل زد يبلغ قرابه 13 مليون ناخب
وفق علماء اجتماع فان هذا الجيل لا يرتبط
بقائد معين اي انهم غير متعصبين لاي حزب
او مجموعه او فئه بل هم جيل متقلب ومتغير
بشكل يومي قلنا
نتحدث عن جيل له توجهات متغيره ومتضاربه
في الترجيح والاختيار نظرا لذلك اذا اردنا
التعرف على توجهات هذا الجيل في
الانتخابات يجب علينا الاعتماد على اخر
الاحصاءات التي تسبق الانتخابات بايام
قليله لان هذا الجيل يغير ارائه بشكل يومي
واذا اردنا تثبيت اصواتهم بصوره اقرب ما
تكون للواقع يجب ان نعتمد دوما على
المعلومات المحدثه عند اعداد هذا التقرير
قررنا اجراء مقابلات مع الشباب في احدى
جامعات اسطنبول لان الجامعات تضم مختلف
المشارب والاراء لذلك كان سؤال الشباب لمن
ستصوتون وما هي الاسباب التي دفعتهم
للاختيار
لست متاكدا بالضبط لكن اتصور باني ساصوت
لكمالك الجدار اوغلو لاني ارى ان الحكومه
الحاليه يجب ان تتغير التركيه اذا نظرنا
الى المسار السياسي الحالي لتركيا واذا
اردنا ان نعرف من سيحسن الوضع الحالي
فانني مازلت متردده
استطلاعات الراي تقول ان غالبيه هذا الجيل
لا يؤيد اردوغان انما يريد تغييرا في شكل
الحكم والياته بما يناسب تطلعاته لكن
الرئيس التركي لديه الكثير من الوعود
الانتخابيه لهذه الفئه ومن ضمنها تاسيس
بنك الشباب والاسره وتسهيل حصولهم على
قروض ومنح ماليه
وملايين الوظائف الجديده
فهل ينجح في استقطابهم صناديق الاقتراع في
الرابعه عشر من مايو ستجيب على هذا السؤال
تمثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي منبرا
اساسيا من منابر الدعايه والوصول الى جيل
الشباب لذلك انشا معظم المرشحين حسابات
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونخص بالذكر
هنا تطبيق التيك توك الذي لجا اليه مرشحون
رئاسه مؤخرا للوصول الى قلوب وعقول الشباب
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات